[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Floyd industry director for
manufacturing and transportation at
Google Cloud
and I am suchitra Bose director for
manufacturing and Industrial Solutions
at Google Cloud
welcome to the second episode of the
smart Factory Transformers in this new
video series from Google Cloud we'll
tell the exciting stories of how
manufacturers are in the midst of a
transformation Journey digitizing
production processes and Reinventing
customer experience using data and
artificial intelligence
in this episode we'll talk about the
machine learning boost for asset
performance and production uptime
something I'm really looking forward to
talking to you about today
if your organization is seeking the
latest digital methods to optimize
machine performance for manufacturing
then this episode was tailor-made for
you
we will share some observations from the
industry and then show you an example of
how manufacturers can create deploy and
manage machine learning in their
operations and do so quickly and easily
by adding vertex AI to an implementation
of our manufacturing data engine and
Manufacturing connect we will first talk
about why this approach is needed in the
industry and then we will turn it over
to our great engineering team for a
demonstration
so how's citricia we're back together
again for this episode it's always good
to be with you
question of course always have one so
why should manufacturers care about
using machine learning in their
operations
uh same here Simon great to be with you
in this episode episode again and uh
that's actually a great question Simon
so the number one priority for
manufacturers is to keep production
going 24x7
and this is influenced by a lot of
factors like availability of raw
materials uh supply chain quality uh
yield production uptime or asset
availability and all those uh basically
you know things which truly happen in
manufacturing but for this discussion
let's focus on production uptime
so when we talk about optimization in
this field we think about the equipment
calibration which is making sure you
achieve the highest and greatest yield
in any given time
and equipment maintenance which is
essentially keeping physical assets and
machines running smoothly and
efficiently and making sure you don't
have any unscheduled downtime
so AI can be applied to provide
manufacturers with actionable advice on
how to optimally calibrate and maintain
their Assets in a cost-effective way and
how to get most output from these
machines and also how to increase the
uptime eliminate any unplanned downtime
and predict and prevent failures
so one Mackenzie study it showed that
using digital maintenance and
reliability transformation companies
especially in the area of heavy
Industries they can increase asset
availability by 5 to 15 percent and
reduce maintenance cost by 18 to 25
percent
there is another McKenzie study which
actually shows that in the area of heavy
Industries manufacturers they have
reported that a higher asset
availability and a more efficient
Workforce have increased profitability
by four to ten percent in some
organizations
but these Lighthouse examples are few
and oftentimes manufacturers they face
challenge when it comes to connecting
their predictive maintenance program to
scalable benefits and that is where
Simon I would like to know from from you
that how can Google Cloud make a
difference yeah now it's a great
question I think you and I hear this
whole all the time from our customers
and you know they they obviously many of
the things you've said there are the
things that they tell us but when we
talk to them about them as well they'll
always Center in on that piece of
predictive maintenance or anomaly
detection it sort of it captures their
attention and then they turn it over to
us and say and so what do you do and I'm
really pleased to say that we're going
to have a live demonstration of how that
works and what we've done is put
together a coordinated workflow and we
believe that workflow itself is actually
the difference plus of course you know
we've added in some things there which
help people organize the information in
a way that makes it very usable in the
first place which is another really
great point to make that the data
Foundation is especially critical in
order for us to get to predictive
maintenance or anomaly detection
so the wonderful thing I believe about
this method is that it can be used by a
data analyst or it could be used by a
manufacturing data scientist and why
it's so easy for them is not only is a
coordinate workflow but we've automated
the acquisition of the data we have a
method for training machine learning
models and deploying them to the edge
and monitoring their performance
this provides them with a way that they
can also continuously improve the model
whether that's running on the edge or if
it's running in the cloud and in
manufacturing we we do this all the time
continuous Improvement is is nothing new
and so if we do it for our processes and
for our machines why wouldn't we do it
for machine learning as well I think
that's really very critical because we
want the automation that machine
learning provides us we want that to be
just not not just automated but we want
it to be accurate we want it to be right
every single time
so typically what we do here is that
concern for manufacturers that it's
difficult that's the last mile for them
is doing the machine learning itself and
then there's always that discussion does
it belong in I.T did it belong over an
operational Tech group where does it
belong and we would say yes it belongs
in both and we'll show everybody today
uh how how that's going to be made
possible
so coming right up my colleague kawo is
going to walk through a sample
implementation that he has put together
of how a fictitious company which is
called symbol fabrication I can optimize
their CNC milling operations by training
machine learning models that will
predict health and mitigate any failures
that might affect production something
that most people will want to do in a
production circumstance whether it's a
CNC mill a plastic injection molding
machine pick and place machine or so on
so without further Ado take it away kawo
hi I'm Carl Fung and today I'm going to
share how you can build a system to
predict assets condition using
manufacturing data engine manufacturing
connects vertex Ai and looker
the number one priority for
manufacturers is to keep Productions up
and running
one of the ways to achieve that goal is
to predict when production machines will
fail and take proactive measures
for our example we have created a
fictitious discrete manufacturing
company called symbol fabrication
eighty percent of symbol Fabrications
manufacturing processes involves Milling
which are done using industrial CNC
milling machines
although their factories Implement
routine maintenance checklist
there are unplanned and unknown failures
that happens from time to time
moreover many of the simple Fabrications
Factory workers lacked the experience to
identify and troubleshoot failures due
to high turnover rates and skill gaps in
their factories
one of the manufacturing engineers in
simple Fabrications
Elena wants to see whether she can use
AI to identify and troubleshoot failures
for her CNC milling machines knowing
that vertex AI has automl for people
with minimal data science experience
Elena decides to use Google Cloud to
build an automl model that can identify
and analyze assets conditions
to validate the performance of automl
Elena decides to find a public data set
that she can use before building the
end-to-end data pipelines from the shop
floor
Elena found a public CNC milling machine
data sets from kago that Maps nicely to
her use case
the data set contains various sensor
readings as features and Tool conditions
as label
she then downloads the public data sets
from kaggle
the features and labels of this data set
are in separate files so Elena creates a
simple python notebook to merge the
feature and label data
next Elena creates a tabular data set in
vertex Ai and uploads the merged data
sets to cloud storage
this might take a few seconds
once the data set is created she
configures an automl training jobs and
directly trains and automl models from
the UI
foreign
after the automl model is trained Elena
examines the model performance in vertex
AI
she then applies the automl models for
batch predictions on mde data that are
stored in bigquery
she configures the batch prediction jobs
to Output to cloud storage for mde to
subsequently ingest the prediction
results and explanations
foreign
once the batch prediction jobs complete
Elena checks how many records were
processed
cost is always top of mind for
businesses we can see that Elena spent
less than 37 dollars for training and
serving a highly performant automl model
note that this cost is not
representative for all asset condition
prediction use cases and the cost may
vary depending on your data and automl
configuration
you may ask where did the data in
bigquery come from well the data is
simulated by manufacturing connects and
processed by manufacturing data engine
before training the automl model Elena
has already configured MC and mde
MC allows manufacturing Engineers like
Elena to configure MD for data
transformation and enrichments
to define the data pipelines for asset
condition predictions first Elena
created a payload to identify the
prediction messages from Pub sub then
Elena created a parser to define the
data transformation Logic for the
prediction payload lastly Elena defined
metadata schemas for enriching the
streaming telemetries
in this case the data pipeline is
already up and running and you can see
the streaming telemetries represented as
tags for each tag Elena configured the
metadata values and where the data will
be stored in Google Cloud
from the mcui Elena can connect to the
manufacturing connect Edge components
directly MCH components are deployed on
the shop floors and allows manufacturing
Engineers like Alina to run Edge
analytics and connect Factory assets to
Google cloud in this case Elena created
an MCH flow to simulate CNC milling
machines telemetries into a local
message broker moreover Elena configured
MCH to stream the simulated telemetries
from the local message broker to pubsup
for mde to process
now that Elena has the end-to-end data
pipelines and ml predictions configured
Elena has to show the insights in an
easy to consume manner for her manager
Andrew
knowing looker's Integrations with
Google data Cloud Elena decides to build
a local dashboards for Andrew to consume
the asset condition
from the dashboard Andrew can see a
high-level overview of his assets
also he can drill down into prediction
messages and analyze the performance of
the model
to investigate further when the CNC
milling machine is worn Andrew can
filter the dashboards by highlighting
the time span that he's interested in
Andrew can then analyze the prediction
results and top important features to
determine why the asset had failed
in some cases Andrew would decide that
maintenance is required to minimize
assets downtime
from the Luca dashboards Andrew can
directly schedule a maintenance request
and contact the supplier
often Andrew wants the ability to tune
the sensitivity of the asset condition
prediction model based on his business
requirements
in the dashboards he can tune this model
sensitivity by filtering on different
values of score thresholds
with this filter Andrew is classifying
predictions as worn if and only if the
prediction confidence score is greater
than 0.8
thus the model is less sensitive to
positive predictions and results in
fewer false positives
you can see that the model accuracy has
improved with the new score thresholds
once Andrew finds the optimal score
thresholds for his use case he can
proactively monitor his CNC milling
machines by creating alerts in looker
the alert will automatically inherit the
filter values from the dashboard
in this demo you'll learn how Elena a
manufacturing engineer can build a
assets condition prediction engine using
manufacturing connects manufacturing
data engine and vertex AI you also learn
how n drew a plant manager can use
looker to visualize and troubleshoot his
assets to learn more you can check out
the open source code for the sample
implementations on GitHub also take a
closer look at the manufacturing
Solutions Elena and Andrew used on the
Google Cloud website and follow the
smart factories Transformer series
playlist on YouTube to see more
manufacturing examples
thank you Kawa and hello everyone my
name is prabhupalani Sami and the chief
strategy officer at springama kavo thank
you again for sharing this great example
and the follow-up Resources by
prioritizing assets using technology
Partnerships and having a people first
mentality around technology and ease of
use we can capture the value from
increased production type and reduced
maintenance costs inside the ecosystem
the next layer of accelerators available
to manufacturers are also important this
solution fit these solution accelerators
provide fit to purpose Frameworks to
solve specific manufacturing use cases
for example manufacturing data engine
can collect store filter and process
data in a data Lake
helps to build Advanced data analytics
ml pipelines and visualization use cases
quickly
we want to highlight a use case that
recent we recently deployed for Caliber
Collision caliber Coalition is one of
the nation's largest Coalition repair
service center with over 1500 locations
in 40 States
we built an ml driven address
calibration platform for Caliber
Collision
Ada stands for an advanced driver
assistance system that is key for
parking and driving functions
during a collision repair address
calibration is a key activity that
involves time and resources
ml driven adapts calibration platform
will expedite repair and also ensure
compliances met
we were able to build an ml driven
calibration platform with over 92
percent accuracy after six months of
extensive testing we were able to
successfully deploy to production
by working with Google Cloud we were
able to use industry-leading AI
capabilities in vertex AI bigquery and
app engine to put them to work in this
very specific manufacturing use case
with great business outcome
thank you and back to you Simon
today we've seen a practical example of
how to create deploy and manage machine
learning in manufacturing operations and
we heard about how spring ml is making
it real for many of their customers
today
we discussed it all starts with a clear
understanding of the asset base and
performance goals Advanced planning and
prioritization is absolutely key
secondly the easier a solution is to
implement the quicker manufacturers can
show Roi relative to the development
investment itself
this also includes engaging with the
right digital ecosystem Partners to
fine-tune and develop new capability on
top of that platform
Google Cloud provides the infrastructure
data platform and ecosystem Partners to
develop AI models uniquely tailored to
specific production line of factory or
the Enterprise
we really hope that you've found the
information we shared today helpful
please reach out and we'll welcome you
on this journey and continue to follow
our manufacturing use case series on
YouTube please and of course on our
website
thank you again very much for watching
[Music]